information all right uh we're gonna
answer your question
the question is uh in
Tokyo Hall what if he blocks with the
second arm okay he's blocking the second
arm
so do it again
you finally go through your hole and he
blocks with the second arm you can keep
your grip maybe not even have to grab
just stop the arm hold on okay one more
time
what if he blocks boom okay
come on over here
I for all of you here as well
so
you have a block
but understand the block
is Young
Young
energy Young
okay so the only reason that a block can
exist
is I
participate in the manifestation of Yong
yang okay if I don't
young there's no block
okay so lesson one
that's point one
point two
Aikido has
an external
and
an internal
reconciliation
so here
this
gets changed to Young
versus Yin
okay
so I do my block
and he goes boom and I push
rather than participate with more yawn I
externally yield and it becomes yet
one more time
so I would like to have a
people come up to demonstrate the
pushing the young Vector okay so I go
here and he blocks and you'll come from
behind him stay there please
and you could do it with one arm
she's that energy
see
so Ah that's yum yum oh I yields
this is low skill
it's in the art but it's low skill okay
the other one
is Young
goes inside
it's internalized
okay and when he goes internal it goes
down
to the Earth
it comes back up
comes back up you know
becomes big yum
makes this Yin
do you understand right the planet is
bigger than his energy so comparatively
big young makes this actually Yin
okay
there is his push
so we can have you push
this is a push
yawn
then he pushes and the external heel
or his energy goes down
inside me
okay you understand because now there's
no yum yum
his energy is going inside me and I
bounce it off
and I can move them because they become
into my young
okay
higher skill
three
do both
highest yeah
okay
so
let's look at something
in the internal
aspect
Wherever We Touch
I
generate that greater Young
okay
doesn't matter where we touch
so for example
if he blocks
do you think
he blocked here
keep let go of this well this goes into
his body you feel that it goes into his
body
so how you're here boom and I use the
both both arms
arms both arms you see I don't go
he he touched pull on both arms both
arms
okay so we'll do equal for example any
block
instead of doing nothing on that arm
nothing
he touched
warm touch use both
so you go out oh he touched
you both
boom touch
use both you see
where we touch
so his
his block is not a block
it's more control point
if I internalize it okay so let's try it
from Egypt
Point number one whenever whenever it
touches you internalize then it's not a
block okay
so Gary touch
you said that I internalize you see well
that yeah I internalize okay that I'm
not over here jerking his arm around
okay so let's say he blocks the arm
you see and his whole body
guess internalized
so we'll have him block
the arm
ah the whole body whole body will move
okay lock the arm whole body
so if you pay attention
if you look at his body
When I Come Around Here look at his
base his structure
I got so much only a little bit of tilt
when he brings the other arm look how
much more tilt
you see but if I
go yum yum it won't work but if now it's
actually easier to move it too much
okay
so he's gonna block oh I'm moving
forward
foreign
it's not a block is it you say boom
block
s
let him touch you
let's say that's off
you see let him touch that
off and hit okay
it's off
[Music]
[Applause]
so this time on and hit
on anything
okay let's try so another example of
whatever I touch okay
so we had uh his strike okay the two
hands do it
we had this block okay the two hands to
it
oh this is how I'm gonna touch his face
nice straight okay I touched his face
the two hands
now I attach then the two hands here
it's a it's another adhesion right so
blue this goes that way let go you see
and this this is what I use okay whoa
this way
so whenever I touch oh
okay
whatever you touch
you internalize
and then you use you either Coke you
project or ID adhere Okay so
here the first one boom it's an adhesion
the third one too is an adhesion
the second one was the Coq
boom
okay okay but if he
comes in blocks
right
um he's oh let's look at this Vector
okay let go
stand up
and correct your posture
over here
do you see
that that's what he's doing there okay
so I'm not going
it's inside and I've moved his butt
inside
and he's pushing pushing pushing I'm not
going
that's yum yum inside
through
okay the internal whatever touches me
gets internalized
Point number two
whatever
you internalize
you take into the kazushi pattern
okay so there's two kazushi patterns
with eight manifestations
so we'll just deal with the two
front inward
and back outward
Okay so
front inward
you're going to have give me a person
over here I'll tell you what to do
the front inward there's four energies
it's going to be in
and down
okay
so she's doing two energies in
and down and in okay
then the out the other one
is going to be up
up
and out okay so on the count of three
you'll go
down and in I'll go up and out one two
three
is how he falls
for the back outward
same thing
you're going to have
in
with down
do you see
and then
out
with up
okay I'll do it here but it's on the
center okay
one two three
so if you look at the ikyo
he's doing the front inward
do you see
so I don't just do he's pushing pushing
I don't do just in internal stuff I
don't go internal hot and do my stuff
here
I'm going to put the external with the
internal your kazushi patterns are an
external pattern
but I generate it internally okay so
he's pushing as you'll be internal
internal
into the external pattern
[Music]
when we go to Coqui Hall is to back
outward
this way
he's gonna go that way
[Music]
okay let's just get the back outward
pattern and then we'll bring the
internal back into it when we combine
the internal
with the external back outward position
the block
helps the throat okay let's try it
so let's go back a step
and he had his block
so here I don't have the kazushi pattern
do you see that I just have the internal
it'll work
but it works better
if I start the pattern because he's
behind it do you see that he's behind
the the resistance angle so then it
works better
do you guys understand that so you can't
do it internally he blocks
but you combine the two and this works
better okay because he loses mechanical
advantage due to the external kazushi
pattern
same thing here
if I go here
out any blocks
I can do this internally
you see
he has a very strong block there you see
that but I can do it
internally
it'll work
but it's not Aikido
it said
I'm going to add here here
is a part where he's touching me and I
make that
go back
so I haven't moved yet I haven't entered
yet
Gary's touching me
so I adhered there to hit Center
so at this point
my arm is not where he can block it
do you see my arm is over here
block my arm
say like just like the other one it
makes his Center go higher
and now makes him easier
to go backwards do you understand
so first you have to fix this part
two
he's going backwards before I enter
to make a block
he's not going backwards and I try to
enter young young
here
internalizes energy
and make it Yin
then I would enter there
do you understand
so next drill
who he let go
you'll get him going backwards now he
can't young my young he's going in okay
try Okay so the adhesion
is on here on this face
on my inside of my arm not my elbow
underneath him not my elbow in front of
his face
on this side
this side
okay
so here
let's say he pulls with two hands now
it's just gonna make it worse because I
if the hand's not important
his Center will go higher because he has
more mass at the top
so I come around he grabs two hands
doesn't matter
he could do it later
so he'll grab there do you see don't put
your arm out there that's Yang Yang
okay he grabs there it doesn't matter
so you try to grab a little later
just makes the fall easier okay so now
okay we'll try that but don't let your
mind go to his second hand keep the
feeling internalize his new touch Point
okay let's try it the common mistakes
common mistakes
no
you go like this
here
so feel feel the adhesion on you got it
okay watch how that is gonna get
increased
you see that right so here I keep his
balance
over here
take his balance
so don't bend your arm
you're bending your arm because you're
doing an external manipulation
internal manipulation it goes this way
it's this way
not here
I want a lot of energy in the spiral
so this is less energy
big energy
[Music]
this way down okay
so never here
you can see I'm pushing on him because
he never gets going backwards no your
hair you're pushy he's not going
backwards yet he has to go all the way
okay try it again don't bend your elbow
no no no no no no
this shape goes this way
boom
boom not like this
okay try it again so internally I use
the adhesion here but also here
to take him into the pattern
you see the pattern
and the pattern
now harmonizes
yin and yang
got it because he's going that way
so he's gone that way when he pushes on
it he's just pushing himself away
do you understand he's helping me not
hindering me okay so I go and he'll push
on me and he'll go back more that way
that's our next drill you gotta kind of
wait till the end okay so boom pop
okay he'll push him because he's going
that way and he'll push himself that way
okay try it
so now
if he touched me early I would
internalize it it would become part of
the kazushi if he touched me late it
will accelerate him into the pattern
more okay
next thing is a martial concept
do not ask everything
of a single tactic
your tactics build on each other you
have redundancy in your tactics okay so
my only goal
here
is that right there
that's it that's all I want out of the
arm
this tilt
and energy going that way that's all I
want I don't want that part
that's not cook you whole
so I go I'll do it slow
that's all I want
now this part comes in
okay and this part too
here's his mask
do you see in that mass I stick to
you see
I'm not I'm not going to I'm not going
like this
the mass
I stick to it stick to it
got it
says it's touching me
so I adhere so when I'm here you'd be
more like this can someone come give him
a hand
you're just a rail okay
so our next drill is come in make
contact make contact
and you're going to first let's just do
the Turning one so here
stick
turn
then the next one I want you to do is
the displacing one so I have ikey ikey
here
koku here
you see can you see that it's just Mass
it's just flesh just like he's here koku
here hope you
Okay so
I would get we'll do
whoa tilt give him some balance then
you'll just move move
in turning
projective
and then
turn and projects
okay try it yeah okay so now you put
down after you project
the head will get light again and it'll
start to fall so you stay up with the
head but I'm not shoving the head
he's already he was already going that
way
and then he's gonna already be falling
when I do the bottom part and then I
just stay up with the head okay
so you're putting it all together
and he can block now
okay but my advice
don't block
because your Center is going to be
really high
okay but you think you could try a block
okay so we'll try a block and you'll see
it won't do anything to me but it'll
make his it came worse okay
internal external utilization but I
don't that would be bad I would I would
stop you and go don't do that anymore
because it's too dangerous and most
people can't land like he did most
people will just buy dick okay so no
more blocking but here boom you guys see
the coaching on the bottom okay I'm
emphasizing that now
because
a lot of you are doing like a trip
and not a projection
you're gonna project him out boom he
goes
boom now okay all right let's try it